Have you ever wanted to dive in places where anyone has hardly ever dived before?
From February to April,...
...you can experience the magnificent beauty of an unexpected underwater paradise...
...in Murmansk, Russia.
As soon as you dive into the water, you enter a different world.
With an amazing visibility of 15 to 50 meters,...
...you glide past steep walls covered in soft corals...
...and anemones like a vast flower garden.
You will come across an enormous variety of silvery fish species, starfish, sea urchins, shrimps,...
...crabs and strange translucent creatures like jellyfish with fluorescent hair...
...in the sapphire blue water.
There are fantastic underwater rock formations, rifts and their occupants.
But there are also attractions above the water.
You can watch seals and seabirds while skiing and riding a snowmobile.
And then there are the famous Northern Lights!
Finally, after a busy day,...
...many people would definitely enjoy the typical Russian steam bath called "banya."